[Music]
[Laughter]
we all want one and you're definitely
gonna need it a horse of course and
zelda breath of the wild
so how and where can you get one of
these sweet steeds
i can answer that warning this video may
contain spoilers but do subscribe for
upcoming zelda tips because after you've
put some hours in chances are you'll
have questions
horses where are they once you make it
out into the open hyrule fields and you
see a horse you can jump on it and tame
it to claim it but it's not that easy
horses vary in strength speed stamina
and temperament higher the temperament
the quicker they can knock you off
generally the darker more solid colored
horses are the real hot heads meaning
for your first horse consider sneaking
up on the calmer spotted ones because
these wild studs may require you to
upgrade your stamina meter a couple
times
as far as taming goes you sneak up mount
and tap repeatedly the l button to
soothe your best in show do this as
quick as possible because once your
stamina runs out you're bronchod off
once you successfully pass the rodeo
congrats
she's yours
but before you hit that trail you'll
definitely want to stop at the nearest
stable here you can register your horse
for 20 rubies which is worth doing for a
few reasons you get to name it
check its stats and bond status you get
a sweet saddle and most importantly you
can now reclaim it at any other stable
in the game once you check all those
boxes it's time to venture out
yeehaw what the heck
touching back on your bond with a horse
you'll want to max this out asap and
gain that trust because if carlore here
doesn't like you
he sure as hell doesn't trust you the
weaker the bond the more easily startled
they are in a fight which is the last
thing you want against a guardian or
during a showdown with an archer like
this jerk right here oh my god oh my god
i'm sorry carlor i'm sorry hungry
want an apple
yeah
there will be times where you really
need to show affection in order to
manage that bond with your horse you
gotta constantly work that soothe button
anytime you see that head shake hear
frantic nay
and especially any time you pull back on
the reins breaking from top speed that's
like a charlie horse for old charlie
here immediately sue them let them know
you care and as seen earlier sharing is
caring horses like apples just as much
as you do so save some for your trusty
steed
other quick tips your whistle to call
for a horse isn't very generous meaning
if you fast travel anywhere you'll need
to find a stable in order to call for
them also consider using fast horses for
traveling and stronger horses for
battles
because front flipping off your mount
and into the action may send your horse
into the line of fire
and there you have it a quick starter
guide to horses if you enjoyed this
video feed us a like and subscribe for
more tips and tricks for zelda breath of
the wild thanks for watching
[Music]
you